warren buffett's favorite market
indicator hits 200
signaling stocks are overpriced and a
crash may be
coming business insider story the
buffett indicator takes the combined
market capitalization
of all publicly traded u.s stocks and
divided by the most recent quarterly
figure
for gross domestic product investors use
it as a rough gauge of the stock
market's valuation relative to the size
of the economy the wheelchair 5000 total
market index climbed as high as
44.3 trillion dollars on tuesday while
the latest estimate
for the first quarter gdp is 22.1
trillion
putting the buffett indicator at 200
percent that reading is well above the
187 it reached
in the second quarter of 2020 when the
pandemic was in full swing and gdp was
12 lower the billionaire investor
berkshire hathaway ceo added that the
indicator hit a record high
during the dot-com bubble that should
have been a very strong warning signal
of the crash to come the yardstick also
spiked in the lead up to the global
financial crisis
making it a useful tool for anticipating
market downturns this is not looking
good if he's accurate it's looking like
market crash is coming
tom what are your thoughts here's my
thoughts on this i don't care if it's
warren buffett or
jimmy buffett if he's drunk in
margaritaville right now
what about this country in the world
right now screams of stability
strength and consistency do i think a
market crash is coming hell
yes okay i don't know when i don't know
why i don't know how
but do i think it'll eventually happen
i'm gonna go with a yes
how many people that are really really
successful in the market have to come
out and say
this thing's about to crash before
people start going this thing's going to
crash
what's his name from the big short um uh
my the doctor what's no no no no no no
no what's his name uh
well he kidding me we follow this guy uh
what's his name
michael murray yeah michael berry yeah
he he said this
three months ago um this is
look uh what what are we gonna do we're
gonna go to negative interest rates i
mean what how much
what what can how much longer can the fl
the fed keep blowing air in this balloon
eventually there has to be a correction
eventually we have to recognize
i mean the white house is still trying
to claim that we're one percent
inflation
with one percent inflation lumber one
number is up 150
people are buying houses at over market
value because they don't think new
houses are going to be built
this thing is coming and it's coming
hard and heavy
this thing now the big thing the big
question i asked i have because
this is something that that's above my
pay grade
how do we insulate ourselves from it i'm
i'm over
leveraged in crypto as it is i'm way
over leveraged in crypto
but how do we insulate ourselves this
thing is coming
we can see it like a slow-motion train
wreck it's happening right in front of
us
how do we insulate ourselves here's a
question for you here's a question for
you
what is the difference between a market
crashing
like it did in 08 in a market tank 38
percent
right i mean it was a scary time when
the market tanked 38 the whole mortgage
you know real estate bubble that we had
or in late 90s when the tech bubble
the whole same thing happened there's
one in silicon valley what is the
difference between a market crash
and uh major hyperinflation what's the
difference
the the time the amount of time it takes
to recover so what is the difference
let me ask the question one more time so
one is the market crashes meaning the
dow goes from
whatever 30 what is it right now 34 000
and change 33 000 and change
so the dow goes from 34 000 to 22 000.
versus the dow stays 34 000 goes to 40
000. but your money
but inflation goes up 10 what is the
difference
i would guess a lot of wealthy people
are going to be less wealthy in a crash
as opposed to inflation where it affects
everybody day to day
that would be my microeconomic
explanation ebbs and flows markets can
crash and then they can rise inflation
never goes back down
so the value will never come back that's
the point so the point is
in a situation like this either
buffett's going to be right
we're going to have a major market crash
or
we're going to have hyperinflation one
of the two is going to happen if it's
good options just so you know if the
market crashes
look everybody loses money okay but if
there's hyperinflation
guess what happens the rich get richer
and the gap gets
white why because the rich own
they have more equity and the poor don't
yeah
the poor are day-to-day cash and
spending so if
it does happen that it is hyperinflation
this means if you don't own assets that
are not duplicatable
you're going to lose a lot pensioners
really really should be afraid
people with pensions if you own assets
that are not duplicatable you're about
to make a lot of money so
but either way it's very important to
understand the difference between the
two market crashes one thing
inflation is another thing inflation may
happen and some wealthy people may be
sitting there saying listen i
should i don't care my you know ten
million dollar uh you know my 100
million dollar real estate portfolio is
now 150 million dollars
yeah people can't afford it i get it
it's expensive i get it but guess what
i'll take loans but a person who doesn't
own any assets they're sitting there
saying
i can't afford to pay ten dollars for
this gas i can't afford to pay six
dollars for this milk
so that's what we're gonna one of those
two is gonna happen and i'm and i'm
thinking the inflation is gonna hit
the poor and middle america way harder
than i know he does could there be
something a little bit more in the
middle like a correction or is he going
all out crash i mean there is a little
bit of a difference there too
we're gonna have both happening at the
same time we're all we are already in
the beginning stages of inflation
whether it gets to hyperinflation i hope
that there's really really smart people
i don't think both
is going to happen do you mean to tell
me you think the market's going to like
where's it going to crash
tell me where dallas can you pull up dow
right now how can they keep rates this
low
no i know that but but can you pull up
dow right now pull up down right now
okay um that was thirty four thousand go
to five year yeah go to the five year
that was good so five years what
uh uh i mean just go to max forget it go
to max okay if you go to max from 1986
okay there's uh 1981 993
1986 keep going slowly do exactly what
you're doing go slowly
okay when do we hit 2000 go to okay 2000
is what
87 okay when do we hit three thousand
go go go go go go go go go let me ask
you this
watch this though but i wanna show you
something here keep going three thousand
keep going
go to the next market uh high before it
drops go to like whatever looks like two
thousand keep going
boom we hit 11 000 right there wherever
it was i just saw eleven thousand okay
eleven thousand one ninety two
give me the low give me the low right
after that what's the low
okay we dropped thirty percent let's
just say now go to the high in two
thousand
seven weight fourteen thousand what's
the drop 500 go to the low
uh 6 500 i remember that yeah 2008 yeah
now go keep going up keep going up keep
going up this entire time
gerrard just so you know we're printing
money this entire time i don't know if
you know that we keep printing money we
keep printing money we keep printing
money we keep putting the money
keep going keep going keep going keep
going 128 months of economic expansion
boom then covet happens it drops to what
18 i think it's 18
if you get it right we've had 6 trillion
since february of 2020
you're right six trillion what i'm
trying to say to you is
i don't think the market's going to
crash
i think inflation and interest rates are
going to hit the market when it does
to me it is a form of a market crash but
those who don't own
assets that are not duplicatable are
about to get destroyed yeah got to
happen
well you know the whole thing about rich
get rich or poor get poor rich kid guy
asked me a question one time chris
he still he got animated he was upset
you rich people eastern
you rich people this was in oh nine two
thousand you rich people
you have all your money probably in
offshore accounts i'm like dude i don't
have i don't have any options
so you you rich people do this i said
what what you rich people
here's what rich people do look at the
gap you cannot tell me this is not a
republican or democratic thing
it is a thing that's happening everybody
agrees that rich keeps getting rich and
poor gets
keeps getting poor yes because there's
this thing called
compound interest if i'm making 12 a
year
or 10 a year and you keep wasting your
money making a half a percent on a
saving account
you're right you are never going to come
losing again you're losing
every single year so you ought to study
how to so
e let's just say inflation happens so
now becomes the hedge how do i hedge
against the market crash
how do i hedge against a market correct
gold what other way
property what other one ethereum
ethereum
okay how do i hedge against the market
crash how do i hedge against a market
crash
depending on my age depending on my age
on where you are maybe go look at the
way your money's
managed how much equities do you have
how much bonds do you have how much fix
do you have
where's your money at based on your age
so you may want to have your portfolio
i'm a little afraid because my parents
have been saving for retirement saving
saving saving
they've been austere for years for
retirement and they're going to save a
certain amount of money that they think
is going to be
good enough for them to live out the
remainder of their life and if
inflation hits that money is going gonna
be halved
so and they and they're not gonna have
the wherewithal and i don't want them to
have the wherewithal
uh and ability to go out and be an
earner into their 70s that's not that
i don't want that for my parents but if
they think that they're gonna save
five million dollars and that's going to
hold them for the next 20 years and that
turns out to be two
essentially two and a half million
dollars in in equity that that's going
to be
that's that's a pretty devastating thing
you know what we're learning today with
the conditions that we have it is so
weird what we've done with print this
printing money thing is a new thing this
printing money is not like a
they robbed us yeah they gave it they
gave it to themselves yes you're right
they did and by the way even stephen
stanley druckenmiller who's a 10 billion
you know guy worth 10 billion we showed
on the last podcast he says
you have no idea how much money i've
made during this time he said they keep
printing money thinking the money flows
through the poor into middle america
every day all the money flows all the
way to the top it goes to raytheon all
i'm saying to you is
the the form of a market crash i think
if it happens it's subtle it's not as
big as people think
maybe a 20 to 30 percent you know there
may be something like that but that's
going to be a time that's not going to
last a long time
the inflation if this happens if
milk goes eight dollars yeah if you're
buying
if gas goes to i produced a gas gun
i predict it's going to go five to ten
dollars gas is
nuts but that's that's but ten dollar
gas is nothing to a person who has money
so i'm trying to tell you ten dollar gas
so so it's not a market crash
it's those who are not making the right
decisions financially today if
somebody's listening to this and they're
saying well pat how do i
how do i fight against this here's what
i will say whatever you're doing
the next couple years make money and
figure out a way
to buy some assets that are not
duplicatable give me an example of
non-duplicatable can
can a person duplicate land okay can a
person duplicate gold
can a person duplicate bitcoin can a
person duplicate
a michael jordan rookie card can a
person duplicate a mickey man
you know the wayne gretzky card i sold
you know the wayne gretzky code did you
hear about what happened with the wayne
rooney
he sold again again that's not your car
there was two
i sold it for 1.29 million dollars okay
six months ago there was two of those
cards i had the psa 10 the other guy had
the psa 10.
mine was a little lesser quality than
the other ps810
the people who knew like there's three
mickey mantle cards right now that are
psa 10 right
52 tops the the lowest quality psa 10
because they
gauge it based on when it was graded so
depending on when your card got graded
it's a more legitimate ps810
so that's how they gauge it so if you
guys gauge a certain area well they're
we giving away psa tens
if you got gauge in a later era they're
not giving away psa 10.
so the the three numbers i'm gonna start
buying packs of cards like lottery
between 15 million to 30 million dollars
the difference between the three mickey
mouse
between 15 million to 30 million dollars
the lowest psa 10 the highest psa 10.
my make my wayne gretzky card i sold six
months ago for 1.29 million it was a
record now
most expensive hockey card ever sold the
record got broken last week the card
sold for 3.5 million dollars
same exact card except owned by the
other guy three and a half million
dollars
because you cannot duplicate a gretchen
source
some socialist is listening this in a in
a brooklyn cafe and their blood is
boiling yeah right now all i'm saying to
you right now is you
have to take your finances very
seriously
market crash fine inflation scary
incredibly scary if inflation inflation
takes place well look at this is
reflecting jimmy carter's administration
and inflation was never higher than then
and the exact same thing is probably
going to happen
i mean he's following the playbook of
one of the least successful presidents
we've ever had well done
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye